maybe it's okay for me to move on yeah
it's a it's a real paradigm shift for me
and I'm sitting here
wondering if I'm making a mistake we've
been separated for several months what
he says no I don't consider myself
married to Mary
like he just made the decision I've
never heard him say that to me yeah from
Sister Wives to one wife left standing
it's been a better year for the Brown
family as Christine Janelle and Mary all
announce the end their Partnerships with
Cody in 2022. you've seen me say on this
show nobody is a prisoner here if if
this isn't working for you
you know I like my life so much better
now there were tears hey it means a lot
to me you came
all right
[Music]
fights you never tried to have really
good relationship with these other
people
and that's the reason I'm pissed off
that's not true it's just I did and
moments will never be able to unsee
[Music]
so let's rewind things a bit and look
back at the year that was continuing to
navigate the pandemic was Rocky for the
family especially with Cody's strict
coveted rules this is so stupid but
that's not how a family should operate
this is this I am just listen I am
frustrated with covid I am frustrated
with being alone
it's just stupid that's when we first
understood just how strained things were
between Cody and Mary do you know how
hard it feels to be like I am an
outsider Robin no I don't feel like I'm
part of the family I have a husband
technically but do I it's a estranged
marriage it's it's a marriage that needs
to work out some stuff Mary's not the
only wife who felt the distance my
heart's shattered to be honest with you
but it's over
the intimate part of our marriage is
over she tells me nothing special
happens in our room
well that's because she's murdered our
intimacy with betrayal fast forward to
season 17 and Christine let Cody know
she doesn't want to be intimate with him
either and was done with their spiritual
marriage
I'm not interested in Intimate marriage
with you anymore
even if you said at this point we could
have intimacy again we could I wouldn't
believe it for a second so for us plural
merge doesn't work
for us marriage to something I feel like
I have more than I've ever felt before
because I was able to make steps for my
future and for my present and so I just
feel more confident as well with the
lows came some highs and happiness like
when Cody and Christine's daughter
mckelty gave birth to her first child
Avalon
so Avalon ASAP padrone is now born
oh my gosh she's beautiful
it's really one of the most humbling
things to watch in this life
is to watch your kids become parents but
shortly after that Christine let the
other wives know she was leaving Cody
which they didn't take well
I'm so worried this is what you're going
to talk about yeah
I'm not happy right now I'm not happy
with this situation I mean how do we
unravel something that's been together
for this long there's something
unraveling I don't just blame myself
but I do believe that as we go through
struggles there's always plenty of blame
to spread around but hey the family did
put differences aside to come together
to celebrate Isabelle's birthday and
graduation we kind of jump right back to
where we were before the thing the covet
hit back rejects very family again
which is really nice yeah they all let
go of the tension for a second and
showed off their singing voices
[Music]
[Music]
but not too long after the party
Christine accidentally revealed her
split with Cody to their youngest
daughter truly and it was heartbreaking
for the mom of six
so mckelty called me right as I was
walking down the stairs into the kitchen
and I said yeah I'm excited to move too
and then I heard a gasp
when I looked behind me and there was
truly
I just know that I'm going to remember
this moment for the rest of my life
as the day I broke truly's heart how the
conversation took place not super
grateful for that and I know that Cody
would have preferred to be there for
that conversation
um but how the conversation went down
she was amazing she was amazing
meanwhile as Christine moved forward
with her life literally as she packed up
and returned to Utah Cody kind of
suggested Mary do the same Cody actually
said to me the other day
he's like why don't you just move up
there
oh I'm like
uh that was not my intention at this
point I just I don't know what to do I
am lost
[Music]
I felt empty the reason I'm suggesting
this to Mary is is honestly as a family
anymore it doesn't feel like we actually
interact that much as with all
relationships you know whether it's
spouses or friends or family or Sisters
You've Got the ups and downs you just do
and it's just a matter of what your
commitment level is those serious
moments were broken up with moments like
this Cody breaking his coveted rules to
officiate a friend's wedding in Oklahoma
I decided to come checking covid numbers
it seems like it's safe to sort of poke
my head out I'm feeling like it's time
to sort of emerge from
all this uh quarantining the
sequestering that we've had
and Cody showed off his dance moves at
the reception
[Music]
I'm just a guy who just doesn't hold
back but when Cody returned back to
reality a family convo turned tense
between Christine and Robin Janelle and
I are super close but I'm not that close
with
the rest of you and for right now
I kind of need it that way
kind of that last little bit of Hope
sort of dying
right now I'm requiring a bit of a
distance to be honest with you I feel
like I'm just starting to get to know me
I really like me
yeah and that didn't sit well with Cody
who went off on Christine
she's treated you like dirt from the
very beginning that's the relationship
you have with her
and that's the reason I'm angry
after the fight Robin broke down in
Mary's arms
laughs
as for Janelle Cody and her butted heads
about her living situation we've been in
Flagstaff for four freaking years and I
don't have a house still I've been
pushing this house of Christine's on to
Janelle for a long time and Janelle's
like stop it she doesn't want to buy
Christine's house
he's not listening at all I'm trying to
be a husband
a father to their children a lover to
two people who may not see eye to eye
that's a real challenge
and on top of that Cody's tension with
their sons Garrison and Gabe caused her
to question their relationship as a
whole but the last few years I've begun
to wonder
if we're compatible anymore maybe this
doesn't
work anymore for me I don't know maybe
this is not a good fit maybe this
doesn't work which leads us to the
one-on-one special where Cody and
Janelle dropped the bomb they're
separated we've been separated for
several months what
so are you separated yes we are
separated then there's Mary's big reveal
she confirmed her marriage is over too
this last anniversary he's like I don't
even know why you called me Mary he's
like like we're not married we're not
acting as married and I said to him then
if that's where we are don't you think
that we should address that publicly and
he said no I don't want to address it
I don't want to address it I don't want
that to be out there publicly because I
don't want that judgment so now Cody's
Cody's only got Robin who's the who's
the only wife he was legally married to
as for where this family goes
well that's to be seen But one thing's
for sure Janelle and Christine will have
each other to lean on during this next
chapter I'm super close with Chanel
that's that's of course very different
uh just Janelle and I are to probably
just continue I don't know if you can be
Sister Wives you know if you're not
really but I just consider tell my
sister if she just always will be and so
we vacation together and we've hung out
together so we're fine together
foreign